these are challenging times for the ski
business if you know that better than
rusty rusty Gregory he's the man I like
to call the king of the mountain he's
chairman and CEO of mountain resorts in
California Southern Sierras with us this
morning from Los Angeles rusty I know
you're enjoying the summer weather in LA
problem is that's the kind of weather
you had all winter in Mammoth after four
years of drought how do you prepare as a
CEO for the 2015-2016 season good
morning eric is good to be with you you
know very difficult to prepare you just
wait for what mother nature offers us
and do the best we can variable eyes
expenses and the hope for as much
visitation as possible what does
variable eyes mean when you're talking
about expenses walk us through some of
the tough decisions you've had to make
as CEO the trick shot is to have their
cost structure in a in a manner that's
commensurate with the revenue you bring
in and with the volatility of revenue
with the droughts we've had in
California we've had to reduce cost
structure significantly which you know
impacts a small rural towns at ski
resorts tend to be particularly in the
West so and you know cutting daily
operating expenses to match the
visitation and revenue of the day it's
just a very hands-on business but in
doing so do you sort of worsen the
experience at this point lift tickets
have gotten so expensive at from your
resorts you know people are really
expecting a luxury experience so if
you're cutting expenses what does that
do for those who are on the mountain you
know it's really a matter of putting
year-round employees out on the front
line smiling a guest so you know the
guests theoretically don't notice and
pricing standpoint actually that skiing
experience has gone down because of
proliferation of season passes really
led by veil and their epic pass so if
you're willing to commit five or six
days a year to skiing the cost per day
is actually quite a bit less expensive
than it used to be years ago you at
Mammoth rusty have a partnership with
some other resorts that offers not quite
the same thing that the epic pass offers
but it's kind of similar right yeah we
are we're part of the mountain
collective with aspen Alta Snowbird Sun
Valley Jackson Hole Whistler Blackcomb
other other big mountains in the
and so if you buy passes from one of the
resorts you get benefits at all the
other resorts so we think it's a great
competitive offer for the vales epic
pass do you worry rusty again with
drought in the far west in this
throughout the Sierras and also
affecting Utah in this inconsistent
snowfall in Colorado and even into the
Northern Rockies in Idaho and Montana
and Wyoming that that there's a
generation of kids who are never going
to see great snow and may as a result
not end up being avid skiers borders as
adults it on the ski business so I worry
all the time there's always been
volatility and weather and clearly
global global climate change is a big
big topic of discussion these days but
you know years of bad snow lack of snow
tends to be followed by years of good
snow and El Ninos back here in
California very warm temperatures in the
ocean so we're very hopeful we're going
to have a big year in in mammoth is
there pressure you're not a bad year yep
sorry stuff hey there pressure to change
your season pass pricing for those who
are looking ahead at whether knowing
that El Nino is here could they make the
argument sure rusty will come for a lot
less money yeah I think so our season
pass sales were down slightly this year
but you know really gratifying actually
consider we've had four big droughts
record droughts in California this last
year being the driest year on record and
our season pass sales and held up rather
well so we've got loyal customers here
in Southern California it's good to be
next to 22 million residents well rusty
it's not inside California I'm hoping
for a big snowfall at Mammoth this
coming season and I'll be back out there
to see you that's rusty Gregory he's the
king of the mountain he's the CEO and
chairman of mammoth resorts